bom dia pessoal meu nome é rafael
retórica 31 anos
eu sou advogado de formação
hoje no entanto eu eu trabalho
basicamente com a inovação é tanta
inovação social quanto inovação
tecnológica entre outras coisas e
organizam um grande festival de
criatividade inovação e cultura chamado
o festival pé foi até citado aqui né
a apresentação anterior e como curadora
com o produtor diretor e talvez festival
muitos assuntos passam por mim pelo meu
sócio pela nossa empresa e quando recebi
o convite da organização para falar hoje
pra vocês um público selecionado e tal
eu falei puxa vida o que eu posso
escolher de todos esses assuntos que
seja útil que seja relevante que que
mude de alguma forma ainda que modesta a
vida de vocês aqui hoje eu pensei pensei
pensei e e eu cheguei à conclusão que o
melhor que eu tenho pra dar é um pouco
da minha história e dessa virada de 180
graus de advogado para o que eu sou hoje
né eu nem sei direito quem eu sou mas
ela se cansou 111 produtor cultural um
cara que trabalha com inovação e
economia criativa a no seu dia a dia
enfim é uma história bacana eu espero
que vocês gostem não durmo eu gosto
começar essa história é indo lá pra pra
fazer do do colégio mesmo né eu morava
nos estados unidos nova inglaterra num
colégio interno
então fui culpado de toda essa tensão
pré vestibular da escolha num isso não
fazia parte do universo então só que eu
me formei em 2002 julho de 2002 e bem na
época do 11 de setembro então os pais
apavorados eles meio que forçar a barra
para voltar então de lá eu fui direto
para o cursinho desde que tiram o couro
mesmo sabe e eu percebi que se eu
quisesse ter sucesso e acabar com aquela
tortura logo estava focado
eu escolhi focar no direito sabe-se lá
porquê talvez para satisfazer os outros
mesmo que eu tivesse com medo né seu
advogado uma carreira sólida ainda hoje
existe um plano de carreira é uma coisa
que é vilaboim o l near fui é um livro
falando esse senhor jornalista minha mãe
falava um advogado pode escrever mas o
jornalista não pode jogar muito bem lá
foi o puck e é entrei para arregaçar
assim foi com tudo mesmo liquidei aquela
aquela coisa horrorosa de cursinho e fui
tateando as várias áreas na faculdade a
fim de fazer o melhor não é daquele
momento eu queria ser um jurista entre
acreditando que é bom é isso é isso
embora me formei passeio a b e c guiné
seguir aquela trajetória bacana eu
trabalhava no escritório grande e
respeitado numa área é de mercado de
capitais e fusões e aquisições mas num
campo de atuação bastante árido é onde
eu basicamente ajudar empresas a mitigar
riscos antes problemas a resolver
problemas e aí fui começando a sacar com
o advogado um cara meio pessimista no
brasil só que isso muito depois mas
olhando para trás eu vejo que isso me
fez ver como eu olhava só para os
problemas do tipo a gente tá aqui nesse
retorno maciço teto cair se pegar fogo
então se você fica um cara meio olhando
pra possíveis problemas
trabalhava muito né com com a abertura
de de capital em bolsa as infusões e tal
e eu sentia que a minha energia vital
minha juventude estava escorrendo a
lipor entre os meses até que um amigo do
escritório e me levou pra fazer uma
vivência ano um curso no interior de são
paulo um zoneamento de três dias
de onde eu vim com ele são muito
importante que é a seguinte o tempo a
coisa mais valiosa que eu tenho que a
gente tem e isso foi meio que o estopim
para eu começar
a áfrica é verdadeiramente incomodado
com aquilo tudo que eu tinha vivido até
então
enfim parece uma lição simples mas ainda
hoje passados anos disso eu eu preciso
me lembrar disso que às vezes a gente
não pode comer bola a gente precisa
chutar a bola pra frente e ver o que
acontece
senti quando eu vou ter esse curso
sempre um grande frio na barriga eu
falei aqui eu não posso mais ficar não
sei o que vai acontecer mas aqui não
posso mais ficar então tinha juntar um
dinheirinho como advogado aluga um
apartamento que na minha casa seria
impossível eu tenho esse ato tem esse
respiro né
a família todo mundo trabalha uma
família italiana meu avô tinha indústria
meu pai tem e não se aceita o ócio na
minha casa
então o local a pé pra ter um pouco de
tranquilidade que começar a pagar aquilo
que eu achava que era uma dívida comigo
mesmo né
saí horrores de segunda a segunda na
balada vir a adotar o filme fez muita
academia já ganhei muito peso por causa
de o habital e é deixe a vida acontecer
um pouco
só que eu percebi que eu não tinha
nenhum talento aparente né eu falei 'bom
eu saí do direito e agora é é quem sou
eu pra onde eu vou que o fazer
aí uma amiga minha falou olha o que você
não vai na fátima toledo fazer um curso
de teatro e tampouco dura sincera jogar
vai lá boa idéia
vou lá só que a fátima toledo gente ela
é uma super preparadora de elenco e tal
ela preparou é para aqueles filmes de
violência tipo se não me engano são de
deus e e tal e quando eu vi eu era o
único nem o ator da turma e eu estava lá
em apanhando batendo chorando foi bom
não seja exatamente o que estou buscando
mas é aquele bicho e ficou então eu sei
lá eu vou achar um outro método em
frente então eu imprensa elena
vestibular passei e seguir em uma fase
muito feliz e tranquila é de novo entrei
pra ser ator e vão embora isso aí
é vamos em frente e rede globo aí vou eu
fiz vários testes de de publicidade e
catálogo e tal e é e fui acreditando é
só que enfim ué muito difícil da atração
da carreira do teatro o teatro consegue
o começo da vida de um ator ainda mais
difícil do que a de um advogado
então eu fui vendo que já está com 27
anos e tal foi bom
talvez não seja isso é e agora aí é eu
abri meu facebook e e eu já sabia que eu
queria estar na comunicação de algum
jeito é a única certeza entre aspas que
eu tinha em abril o facebook foi bom que
é a única pessoa que eu conheço que pode
encaminhar esse meio é um grande amigo
meu tinha aberto uma uma produtora do
lado da minha casa uma produtora de
filmes publicitários pequenininha mas
que enfim e representava um mundo novo
para mim e eu cheguei ele foi caindo eu
faço qualquer coisa eu quero estar aqui
eu quero trabalhar por belezas e vai
montar sete de publicidade e ver o que o
então beleza eu comecei a enfim aquela
era uma disney pra mim sabe o tipo 7
câmera diretor cenógrafo o ator e tal
era era onde eu achava que ele estava em
3 de novo pra o produtor 7 embora e suma
somando um pouco melhor o advogado eu
fui galgando naturalmente algumas
posições lá dentro é um lugar muito
pequena então eu comecei a ver contratos
e contas a pagar e tal viria uma espécie
produtor executivo
só que eu tinha 11 insight que foi o
seguinte a gente aqui tem um monte de
gente criativa nessa pequena produtora
que não abre a boca porque o a idéia vem
pronta da agência e você ea gente
executava então foi uma certa desilusão
uma baita desilusão na época foi bom e
não é isso que os criativos fazem vai
criar e
eo ser muito louco e tal não vem da
agência você monta vi uma entrega
totalmente processual e tanto quanto sei
lá uma fusão de uma empresa com a outra
aí é um grande amigo meu único rodrigues
que é fundador e presidente da box 1824
uma empresa que eu admiro muito me
chamou no canto falou olha vamos fazer
um coaching é reunir um cara muito
ocupado com ele quando ele me deu essa
chance eu agarrei vamos então abri minha
vida pra ele
a gente fez é um processo ele falou olha
eu acho que atua o teu caminho é contar
a história muito bem
aí eu mexa os pauzinhos e preparar uma
grande produtora dessas que produz além
de publicidade conteúdo para tv e cinema
era uma procura grande reconhecida cheia
de de bons contratos de bons produtos
é enfim parecia 11 o asa tem uma coisa
de louco porque é é onde eu queria matar
ele só eles tinham uma constância de
produção que é raro de ver no mercado
essa época tinha acabado de passar uma
lei que obrigava os canais a cabo a
exibir conteúdo feito produtora nacional
então era uma época do boom do mercado
do produtor então ficará é um sinal de
deus é aqui que eu tenho que está mesmo
inspirado
o gol então é eu fiquei lá um ano
tentando estabelecer como produtor
executivo fazendo tudo que eu podia
aprender e fui percebendo que com todas
as condições adequadas
a gente não conseguia colocar na rua a
os produtos com colocar na rua entenda
veicular a as séries e filmes com a
devida rapidez
isso começou a ir lá um pouco porque eu
falei gente é eu não quero ser uma
pessoa que vai realizar pouco né sentido
numérico mesmo não quero ser um produtor
de duas três séries
vida ou quatro filmes eu queria fazer
mais e ouvir que se tudo tiver um lugar
se você tiver uma equipe maravilhosa um
contato bom no canal uma linha de
crédito o governo as coisas demoram
nesse meio e não era para culpa da
produtora nem nada era porque mesmo que
o mercado era assim eu acredito que
segue sendo assim então pra você fazer
uma série bacana dois ou três anos um
filme 45 anos e aí acho que o céu é o
limite
eu falei 'bom o outro baita frio na
barriga né foi bom e agora também não é
isso num não é que vou fazer vou encarar
já estava beirando os 30 e aí o roni é o
grande amigo e coaching
acho que ele sentiu culpado e talvez ele
falou vem aqui trabalhar a boca vem aqui
se um cara bacana você tem garra entre
acreditando nos lugares nos dá tudo de
si em cada dia tenho o maior respeito
pela vox porque a box é uma empresa
ainda hoje transgressor ela estudava o
comportamento jovem lançava tendências
nesse sentido muito fortes e que de
certa forma ensinavam todo mercado e tal
então eu fiquei com aquilo me intrigava
muito em conta tendo o povo convite para
integrar esse mundo a fazer parte disso
né é uma energia muito boa
só que aí vem aquela questão não tinha
uma formação nem antropologia nem
psicologia nem publicidade nem nada o
que que eu ia fazer na box né
eu tive que ir mais ou menos
naturalmente foi meu caminho pra o
atendimento ea prospecção de novos
negócios
lá eu aprendi um pouco a a a atração por
um negócio sabe a alimentar um negócio
porque a gente tinha que ir pra rua e e
achar trabalho e e vender aquela ideia
maravilhosa que a box que era muito
fácil ser vendida porque é realmente
e aí fazendo enfim desenvolvendo novas
habilidades em mim e consegui uma uma
pequena rede de contatos
só que aquilo não eu não era talhado
para aquilo que não fazemos muito muito
encorajadora se tudo aquilo não fazia
sentido pra mim né não era não era uma
coisa que pudesse para puxar no médio
prazo voltar aqui ou no longo já estava
um pouco certo disso quando eu entrei e
aí eu falei caramba mais uma vez é eu
estava sem rumo é pra onde eu iria com
tudo toda a bagagem que eu tinha um modo
talvez não tinha acumulado muita coisa
não o suficiente pra mim e me recolocar
em algum outro lugar porque enfim um mês
isso tudo isso foram experiências mais
ou menos rápida então um dia que eu tava
indo eu não sabia talvez descobrir foi
conseguir alinhava tudo isso mais tarde
aí aconteceu o que eu acho que é um
golpe de sorte um belo dia toca o
telefone e uma amiga fala assim a rafael
é ter um grande arquiteto norueguês que
está reformando uma creche e esse
projeto está no catar para quem não
conhece o catar é um site de rateio de
projeto de decreto fã dele onde você
consegue financiar boas idéias em
conjunto com outras pessoas
enfim essa amiga sabia que o que eu
gostava de apoiar esse tipo de projeto
quando fui ver as contra partidas pelo
apoio
tinha uma que chamava conexões bárbaras
quer um encontro com a bárbara soalheiro
a bárbara ela é uma menina muito legal
uma das criativas mais um dos maiores
expoentes aqui de são paulo talvez ela
tinha sido editora chefe da capricho já
que já tinha um projeto muito legal
chamado mesa e cadeira e falar com ela
seria um privilégio assim pra mim então
não tive dúvida cumprir a cota por fazer
uma sessão de melhoria com a bárbara
chegando lá ela falou olha vou te
apresentar tal cara a cara já conheço
esse outro é isso aí também já conhece
bem ou mal já tinha uma pequena estrada
na comunicação né e aí ela falou olha a
fael eu não vou desistir de você a gente
vai continuar essa melhoria mas só
depois que eu voltar de oz tem por que
barack que vai fazer lá ela foi uma
palestra num evento que mistura
tecnologia com o empreendedorismo
cultura com música com o cinema onde o
twitter foi lançado a nata da comunidade
global criativa se encontra lá no ano e
meu olho foi crescendo com tudo aquilo
foi bar onde é isso que é isso e era o
sxsw em austin muito bem eu cheguei no
meu pai e falei 'pai eu preciso itaú já
não aguentava mais militar dinheiro me
me ajudar essas empreitadas malucas e
fui o e certo de que eu ia voltar com
alguma coisa na mão eu vou arrebentar
vou conhecer alguém importante que vai
haver uma porta fazer algum negócio
voltar com alguma ideia patentear a
alguma coisa acontecer e foi lá eu
conheci o meu tom sócio fábio seixas
entre outros brasileiros muito bacanas
que estavam no evento naquele ano 2013
e quando a gente voltou
o fábio me chamou pra olhar os contratos
da conspiração filmes e lembrou que o
advogado na época era diretor de núcleo
da conspiração
quando cheguei falei não eu não tenho
mais a mão e não tenho mais a confiança
da opinião aqui nesses contratos mas eu
acho que a gente podia fazer um festival
como esse de oz tem aqui provocar a
comunidade daqui com esse tipo de
formato e ele adorou porque o fábio já
era um cara super conectado com vários
universos e o sócio perfeito pra gente
por a idéia em prática e fazer aquilo
que rodar e apesar de tudo isso eu me
sinto só começando no festival ele vem
numa crescente muito forte é eu vi
vários assim palestrantes aqui no tek
que já passaram por lá eu tenho um super
orgulho disso é preciso ter uma idéia a
gente começou em 2013 como projeto
piloto em 2014 cresceu a gente conseguiu
três patrocínios apoios e em 2015 foram
cinco mil pessoas em 30 palestrantes 19
bandas 10 18 21 filmes tudo pensado para
abrir a cabeça e ajudar pessoas que como
eu
tem uma inquietude 11 uma dificuldade
talvez fazer escolhas
mas enfim é um trabalho que me move é
onde eu me encontrei onde eu posso me
aprofundar em vários assuntos e várias
pessoas e conhecer muita coisa então é
uma realização sem fim mas eu acho que é
é uma coisa que não está pronta e que
não é preciso mudar e me transformar
muitas vezes pra melhorar isso e abrir
mais portas e evoluir
então eu queria terminar deixo uma
pergunta talvez né como não engessar
depois de uma trajetória tão improvável
como a minha e como a de muitos de vocês
né meu coração aberto em paz com a nossa
história ser sincero né até onde a gente
vai se a gente ver com propósito eu acho
que longe muito longe mesmo
então é isso obrigado até a próxima